I want to send just a massive thank you
to everybody who has responded quickly
aggressively and and sort of with
confidence in terms of replacing the
insanely crushing revenue loss of the
YouTube advertiser boycott that we've
been experiencing I won't rehash the
entire thing right now we've done a
number of clips about it but hundreds of
people have donated at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and have signed up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and i want to keep it going
we are on our way to making it so that
we don't have to care about what's going
on with this insane youtube advertiser
boycott signing up for membership is
really really easy you go to david
pakman.com slash membership will put up
a picture of what that looks like for
you and as you can see here you can use
the monthly or yearly button to either
sign up on a monthly or yearly basis and
then you can take that red dot and drag
it wherever you want as you start
dragging right you're contributing more
and more either monthly or yearly we
with trump's approval rating it's been
limbo how low will it go with the red
slider it's how high will you go how far
to the right will you go and of course
when you do sign up for membership you
get the member the bonus show on which
we've dealt with close to half a dozen
scandals involving producer pat forde at
this point those are usually got into in
detail but we all show is where i swear
i shine i would say really yeah well
usually because you're defending
yourself from often unfair attacks i
would say i'm on record as saying many
of those scandals have been unfair but
we also get to tech stories world news
stories of stories we just don't have
time for on the regular show a lot of
interesting stuff and you're supporting
the show okay so david pakman.com slash
membership that's one of three ways that
you can easily support the show okay so
the three ways that you can support the
david pakman show which we will put up
on the screen for you our number one you
get a membership at david pakman.com
slash membership number two you go to
patreon patreon.com Backman show donate
a buck or two five bucks 1020 500 250
whatever works for you and number three
if you ever shop on amazon you stop by
david pakman.com slash amazon before you
do your shopping it'll send you to the
amazon website and then anything you buy
will send us a five to eight percent
kickback so three ways to support every
single one of them it's american dollars
its currency it's fungible it doesn't
matter if it's a dollar we get from
youtube or a dollar we get from patreon
it's a dollar and that's why we we are
just so thankful to the hundreds and
hundreds of people that have already
activated helping to replace that lost
revenue